we're going on a ship fun oh I forgot to
pack my seos will you be able to
supply will there be gluten-free dairy
free options on board gluten makes me
bloat and I want to make sure I look the
best for the welcome
party is there a juicer I'm bringing
lots of celeries so we can all start our
cleanse together what are the facilities
like I normally do boot camp with Johnny
three times a week he's so good but I'm
sure I could good buy with a yoga mat
some ankle weights and a standard set of
3 to 20 lives do you think we can make
that
work oh I know the lack of gravity makes
you we less so if I were to get on the
scale will the number just read zero
because I need to get a photo of that
from my ww Facebook
group okay we're
[Music]
ready